[Music]
come on you going to finals go out to
the finals I'm so excited I know you're
a competitive guy but like to talk a
little bit from the beginning of this
journey and not to where you are now
is there anything you can't do and how
do you feel I feel great
first of all and the beginning of this
journey you know signing up didn't know
what I was getting into no I knew I was
going to learn how to dance but if you'd
have told me I'd have made it to the
finals I wouldn't I want to believe you
but being here is so thrilling and we
get to finish do something like super
spectacular and strong I'm excited with
a leaderboard I think you are alternate
technically you're on top of the leader
board because Simone is out yes yeah the
couple leaving right now is Simone and
Sasha I know you're celebrating it is
but at the same time you know you're
Sasha's on his way out so it's a little
bit of a mess
uh yeah you'll see Marisa no no no no no
I got I went through okay there's a
couple of reasons why I went through the
whole thing just now and I am I go on an
emotional roller coaster but but he
Sasha is completely fine Simone is like
she's they're so happy that's so
positive it's not you can't be really
down about it like I'm absolutely gutted
of it where they don't get to do a
freestyle and I don't get to support
them I thought they were going to go all
the way on its Lane speaking at
freestyle coming out what like what
natural talents that this guy has that
you're going to utilize for that
freestyle extends from the corners of
his mouth
he's gotta love to get better I just
want to make it off like a big
celebration
[Music]